citizens of the reject Nation we are here once
again for the Last of Us seven of nine it's the
Star Trek crossover episode and joining me
once again is my very excellent co-host Tara
Erickson Tara how you doing today hi guys dude
I'm so excited are you excited yes I am dude
it's still pouring rain outside it's the perfect
dreary weather for a Last of Us episode why don't
you guys go ahead first and foremost follow Tara
uh go go you got some new stuff going down right
you're trying to do so right please follow
Ellie eats and drinks on Instagram it's also
on Tick Tock and YouTube but I'm going around
to restaurants and bars and cool places taking
video editing them and doing a little voice over
and just get up on there you know and support it
as well as subscribe hit the like button for this
Channel and don't forget to ring the bell foreign
you get it and the patreon check out our
patreon.com the real rejects if you want
to sync up and watch the full experience see
everything that gets cut out of these reaction
highlights you can also check out the watch
along for Greg and Andrew's video check out
the reaction highlights as well and uh hey
if you want to rock some real reject swag
go on look at our xeroddition.com store got
tons of stuff to keep you warm during these
waning winter months including Greg's new
game over design inspired by The Last of Us
and uh Hey without further Ado I think
we're ready to go let's do it let's do
foreign
oh yeah you were supposed to be working on
the song and I was supposed to be working
on my fungus costume wow that's
where we're failing this week
if you for those of you playing
along at home I'm sorry no updates
next week for the whole musical number and for
the last episode I'll I'll wear something fungacy
sinister feel the chill
she dragged him all the way here
come on fighter Joel leave
shut up Joe shut the [__] up
you're gonna die an old old woman
warm in your bed not here is life
oh ouch there's no way she's coming back
that was a strong silence just there
oh
we go we're going to do a flashback
I think I have that walk man laughs
oh I hated PE I clearly excelled I have
PTSD just watching this p-e-t-s-d all right
oh come on dude pick up your pace I don't
want to fight about it your friend twice
she's not here anymore is she what okay yes
that was you and P yeah never been when I
called well behaved but the last few weeks
you got spunk kid we need more of that around here
you're promoted you're smart Ellie
Ellie you're so smart you're stupid
you do take [__] or probably be Bethany
naughty dog all the rules you become an
officer you get to tell the bethanies
of the world exactly where to shove it in
their bum so which way jeez good pep talk
hey this otter be good dang wait [__] that
means she had a joke book all the way back then
deep does the pun book go oh so she's
already lost people so she can't lose Joel oh
Mortal Kombat that's where Ellie got it
oh Riley Where Have You Been what the
[__] is wrong with you sneaking up
on me like that it was a joke okay in
my mind you loved it a storm read damn
you've been gone for three weeks where were you
damn toughest nails I joined the fireflies you
I'm not in the mood for this Riley I'm really not
you're a firefly Jesus come with me for a few
hours and have the best night of your life
it's 2 A.M in a few hours I have drills
get dressed not anymore oh boy
ain't nothing bad gonna happen today
take on that cassette where are we going
you trust me right I don't know should I
trust you of course you should with your life
can you trust Ellie with your life
guards no dispatcher's [__] stupid
maybe you should stop [__] with Bethany
I'm sorry you're telling me not to beat
people up you put Carol in the infirmary for
a [__] week you can pick and choose what's
important oh are they teaching you this at
Firefly University kinda Fu nice and Gerald
Carol yeah Carol always hated Carol oh Firefly
lights are better one point for the anarchists
we prefer Freedom Fighters whatever Firefly
Freedom Fighter good alliteration all around
oh [__] oh no this guy wasn't here yesterday
surprise no thank you
score they're gonna get smashed smash no one told
him he couldn't mix pills with that [__] I think
oh my great oh my goodness
okay that's a good fake out
yum
I do not approve of this underage
drinking I do supposed to be a role model
they're about to have somewhere
the kids come to these reactions
I got bored so I snuck out I was on my way back
and this chick popped out of nowhere like 40.
whatever anyways old said she was impressed
watching me sneak around she's like all right
if you wanted and in a way Federal kind
of holds everything together as much as I
love arguing with your stubborn ass you're
on a mission here oh rooftop Chase parkour
I guess Federer stands for the fascist oh
I had it damn you had a whole accident you
only got one word one word I'll get it I'll get
there okay fascist Ensemble of dumbass racist
[__] there you got it fireflies blowing
up the stories people didn't help again
the [__] yeah so you don't bomb stuff anymore
now when civilians are around that's propaganda
the mall you out of your [__] mind
they sealed that place off for a reason
it's full of infected it's sealed off
then why isn't it sealed off propaganda
let's go shopping Montage that's trying on clothes
but they're all covered in Vines and foliage this
is where they find their virus outfit apocalypse
Chic we're gonna go through there then turn right
you'll see a door go through it wait are you
gonna kill me this seems like a perfect place
to do it oh I'm aware what what is this gonna
be is it a surprise party I'm here now what
be needing that yes yes yes oh wow yes
I love it oh look at the whole place to
yourself and you ain't seen nothing yet
tonight I'm going to show you the four
wonders of them all you plan stuff
oh it's like a little date I ship
them I'm sure Riley is Alive and
Well in the present I ship them electric stick
escalator temporarily stairs
except not not at the moment stairs
temporarily escalator this is so cool backwards
it's a good exercise
careful are you
up oh that was a little high smell love
oh me cute right there why are some of
these drawers empty and some not stuff that's
gone is the stuff that people need it the most
sneakers and not soap or that
[__] I mean I don't get what
looks uncomfortable what nothing
I was just trying to imagine you
wearing them shut up oh golly all
right come on you're almost there
oh
Eleanor so cute it's okay you're perfect
sister you're already halfway there yeah
come on oh I love how they're building
this up gradually open your eyes
wowie what what well has a carousel
I want that mall dang cool beautiful
well hers and hers horse ride
oh
all right pour one out for that dead
guy he really hooked you up tonight
oh why now come on dang you
know we can make things better
sewage detail
standing guard while people shovel
[__] that's what they think of me
oh you know you're the one thing I miss
from that place if that makes a difference
no
kiss kiss I know right we're two wonders
down three more to go if you want to keep
going I don't know how it's supposed to get
better oh you'll see rooftop swimming pool
oh photos the photo booth this is the best
date ever that's so cute this is where the
kiss is gonna happen I'm oh you I came prepared
have you done this before idiot I was waiting
to do it with you oh where'd you get that
fiber oh [__] um Jerry just care okay
okay sorry oh
oh my goodness I love the
tension ah I feel it all listen
yeah let's do this awesome show me to the pinball
this is the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
oh what not not me you ball
it up not your buddy Riley
where's the ski ball where's Mortal Kombat oh yeah
not a ripoff of Mars Attacks
coins you can't even play once
yeah I'm the same [__]
that spent an hour yesterday
breaking this oh you're really
prepared best date ever dude
uh you ready test your might test your mic but
who do they each play as it's the real question
foreign
let's do some creepy dolls
in this story why not to
um
oh yes oh boy oh Network the network has awakened
way to go Baraka
so close please die by butter lettuce head and
never get to kiss I have to wake up and move my
bed soon we we still have a few hours left yeah I
just can't get in trouble again I got you a gift
oh
I do like gifts is it a spider
is it in your shirt nope is it
a water pistol better better
possibly I mean is it a pistol that shoots spiders
oh what did the frustrated cannibal
do laid on me he threw up his hands
that's awesome how does a computer
get drunk it takes screenshots
oh we'll explain don't worry here
gator in a vest
bomb Fixins we would never use them on you
or anywhere ever near you I would never let
them do that do you never let them right and
you think they're going to listen to you yeah
yeah point even about me would
you stop Q Ellie Ellie I'm leaving
they're sending me to a post in the Atlantic
YouTube tonight's my last night in Boston oh
what a conflict why did you bring me
here because I wanted to see you and
and I wanted to say goodbye there it is n't
easy Ellie it actually is you just did it oh
good bye this is depressing what are you
talking about funniest scene in the show
ruining the comedy Terror you don't get comedy
foreign
oh my gosh
laughs ah surprise I thought you'd like
this one the best so I saved it for last
Spirit Halloween is never stupid fireflies
aren't what I think they are but they chose me
I matter to them you matter to me first
you're my best friend we'll miss you and and
I love you let's make out now yes let's break
this tension please one last thing ah yeah get
it on stupid why and this music sucks Thief
Good Taste of music
this must have been fun to shoot
mask kiss come on come on come on come on
oh
damn I'm sorry
foreign
what do we do now we're gonna figure it out
uh get ready to run
whoa oh my goodness oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy okay oh my God oh my God foreign
well done
reaction huh
oh the light
no no no no no no no no no no
oh on damn it
it's got to be something full of snow
quick painless two
yeah that's two minutes
two days we don't give that up I could just
be a poetic [__] oh watch option three
God lucky seems like the odds could really
go either way for a needle and thread
come on Joel
oh yeah give him something to bite down on
ah let's do this yes do this
this is the first time I've ever
seen a triumphant suturing Montage
got this girl
I hate that it's over I hate that it's over I
am in a whirlwind of emotion right now and I
get so I'm mad I'm mad after the last one
and now I'm like oh my God this is I just
love I love this show too much I just I don't
like when it ends I know I can't I know and
now we have to wait a whole other week and all the
alternate timeline where they drop this show all
in one go we're sitting there going why could they
space these out with the week no I feel you oh I'm
exhausted right now oh my god oh well hmm we got
we got some stuff to talk about terrorists yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah boy howdy all right
Tara what did you think what did you think
so stupid like uh it's it's a beautiful episode I
loved the Callback where rip Ripley is your name
right right Riley Riley right Riley says do you
trust me and it's such a great callback to Joel
saying do you trust me and I remember the same
look in Ellie's eyes when he asked that and now
you get to see why her reaction was that way when
Joel asked is because of this whole entire episode
and yeah it was it was great I'm still mad I'm
mad that it ended I'm upset but yeah it's another
like roller coaster of a of an episode that
oh sure absolutely an emotional rollercoaster
I love the the way I mean this one you know
obviously being that it surrounds Ellie you
know is is less of a detour than say a bill and
Frank episode but I I do love the way that they
are willing to dive into these very intimate and
very human personal aspects of the story and then
use the conceit of the show against you like
you're constantly sitting there going some shoes
about to draw there's gotta be like a horde of
infected just around the corner and like it's not
what the show does but they yeah I just think they
they do this really great job of Never Letting you
forget what this world is like what's at stake
what the threats are and yet so often it's not
that stuff that breaks through it's it's just the
real life circumstances and so I love the back
and forth of them kind of dancing ideologically
around fedra versus Firefly life and why each of
them is sort of at least at the moment you know
falling into they're both in two different Lanes
and they both see very differently and yet
you still have this really beautiful little
relationship between them and yeah it's like it's
harsh it's tough she finds the bomb and and she's
you know Riley's leaving to go to the Atlantic qz
or whatever like there's there's so many little
wedges being driven and yet above it all you just
have this really beautiful and tragic Little Love
Story unfolding and uh and again this is another
one of those episodes where I'm like what was what
was this like in the game was it or was it in
the game like I know they expanded heavily upon
Bill and Frank for this story uh and and I know
that I believe again do my best not to read much
but I believe Riley is a character uh because she
was alluded to before and people were like oh man
uh and yeah to see her here now I'm just like what
was the impact in the game what did you have to do
yeah did you have to like run around and pee
and then you got in a fight and you like you
know what I mean you had that black guy yeah yeah
definitely definitely you had to fight uh a bunch
of Boss Battles of PE yeah and then you go talk
to the one soldier dude and then uh I would love a
version of the game where you could just work your
way up to becoming a Federal Officer and that's it
no Grand emotionally moving story just yep status
quo done federal agent uh but yeah yeah this was
really lovely and wonderful and I love the
way they they use them all like like great
I think anytime you're in a post-apocalyptic
infected Story You're nodding to Dawn of the
Dead when you're in a mall but I love
the way they used it for fun and wonder
and and yeah attention tons and tons of like what
of romantic and dramatic tension yeah like every
wonder I was like is it gonna happen now and
they went through six wonders like what yeah
man and like when she leaves I thought that was
such a great fake out when when Ellie walks off
and she goes into that Corridor and you're like
okay here it comes now we got a whole no it's
just the emotionality of the situation and then
having it take place on the day they both get
bit is like that much more of like a devastating
layer to add to all this so on top of already the
tragedy of them being torn apart by circumstance
now you have like the finality of the world that
we're in and right after Riley said she was going
to stay it's like she you of course knew that
they're both waiting they to to basically come
out or Let each other know know that they like
each other and now that it's like finally out and
they both felt safe and Beginning of the End sure
oh man you know Ellie's been thinking about
that forever I mean I'm sure they both have but
it's just so sad that they had the chance
to basically open up to each other and like
basically let it be known that they liked each
other and then within like 10 a span of 10 minutes
they're both going to die now yeah yeah for all
they know for all they know and I and and I and
I mean I don't know if we'll ever cut back to
this I thought it was interesting where we left
off you know because you do leave off at like the
crescendo and I I appreciate I'm curious it's as
to how that'll sort of germinate through my mind
because they do leave you off in that place where
they are just sitting together resigned to the
truth and and now really taking in the finality of
the last minutes they'll spend together and then
using that to cut back to Joel for the bookending
contrast of like no if I have the opportunity I
will not let you slip away because yeah I couldn't
save her because of obvious reasons but I can save
you if I have the right tools and I'm not gonna
leave you and like yeah just the building of Joel
and Ellie like I love an episode like this that
has barely any Joel and yet you feel the impact
and the bolstering of the relationship between
Ellie and Joel because of this even though it's
such a different kind of relationship you know
it's it's it's like a father-daughter kind of
thing and it's a it's all trust and I thought
that was a really beautiful kind of detail like
you said at the top you know bringing back that
element of do you trust me yes and how big of a
deal that must be in this world and two I mean
the little similarities like you know uh Riley
seems musically inclined Joel's musically inclined
they're like ways in which again in like a
non-romantic way but there are just ways in which
like their personalities kind of match like you
would get how they would also be friends despite
the odds and she and Riley even have like a rye
sort of back and forth kind of ribbing so it's
just like a beautiful characterization I thought
and the two of them you know this was I love an
episode two like this that will you know isolate
one or two characters and just make it about that
and let these two actors really play and really
you know give back and forth uh I thought storm
read and Bella Ramsey both did a terrific job here
yeah I want to see the rest of I hope that the
next episode we show the rest of them at the mall
I just I gotta know what happens I I want to know
I know everyone's like what but why but I'm like
but I wanna I want it I want it I don't care if
you don't want it John doesn't want it I can feel
I can feel a torn Terror he's torn there's still
a couple hours left I'm like just show it I want
it I want I want to know you want the director's
cut of this episode yes this is three hours long
it's in real time I do all the way up until Riley
finally turns I do and then Ellie freaking out and
be like what the what what the hell why did I get
so lucky going back to find Marlene Marlene I'm
sorry but but also don't shoot something's wrong
it's been way more than six hours or whatever
the bite range is supposed to be for you know
upper extremities they they have to they if they
get six hours they get to have one last hurray on
the mall that's maybe the storm through Victoria's
Secret not like put anything on not anything weird
but like I don't know well I mean you know but
maybe they're both they're both uh they seem
appropriately aged together yes you know so they
could have a a galavant through Vicky's secrets
why not and you know we were just fun not filming
you right no one would see it would all be if it's
subtitled we would do some kind of thing where
we pan to the front of the Victoria's Secret and
then into some kind of trans are removed of the
lingerie because we know where it went oh see he's
doing it the smarter way I was doing it like let's
just make it a whole different thing like let's
just you the camera stays in there and then it's
just a narrator all of a sudden out of nowhere
we get to narrator voice saying and they went and
they they consummated their yes of their Vitality
but not before Ellie put on some lingerie yes
that was fit for her maybe a boy short not a thong
I feel like she'd be in a boy shirt okay yeah
and then the narrator and then the narrator comes
out and then they walk out and the the narrator's
never heard of again it's just a a quick blip see
that's what we need now is to figure out uh uh who
the narrator should be yes and what uh style what
cut you know each character prefers two ladies
went into the Victoria's Secret and two hours
later they knew absolutely in love like that okay
so you know like Kate Blanche had to narrate or
just or Terror you know what I'm saying I mean did
you hear dude what I just did I thought you were
British now have you been lying to me with this
American accent the whole time we've been doing
the show it's so awful I think when I do it um
friends who know it's bad say that's a bad accent
uh believe in yourself love you're good you see
John's good money you do it right don't even worry
about it you're doing great we're doing good super
chuffed this is fun it is yeah yeah as in the next
reaction we'll just do all birds just all of it
we'll just do all Cockney reactions from now on
well yeah man you got any stray thoughts I love
that they ended up in a Halloween store Spirit
Halloween's the best yeah so good got the good
masks finally yeah didn't have to pay 150 bucks
for one of them I was like oh I would not want
to dance around in those masks I don't even want
to wear one of those masks for not they're not
cool but for more than five minutes there you get
sweaty face in like a minute and your head smells
like rubber yeah and you can just smell your own
breath yeah and that plastic and that hot plastic
is warming up your nasty breath and then it's like
you gotta have like a pocket full of mints yeah
even then it's I don't think it does it justice
and I like that that infected waited till they
were at the Halloween store to attack just so he
had the best that's that's smart you know that's
camouflaging your attack that's a good strategic
move I really wanted to see butter lettuce head
break away from the rest of the lettuce behind him
though we didn't get to see that that was he was
in that right and I was like I want to see how he
gets out yeah they don't they don't do much extra
perspective oriented stuff right but I would have
loved to have seen that right and I hope that
before the show yeah if season one doesn't do
season two better do it I need to see the butter
lettuce disconnect from the other lettuce yes yeah
yes jump right out of that salad yes go based upon
some some young ladies or anybody really who's at
the mall that's a great Hideout though and uh and
I'm so glad they have these amazing ass generators
cheap to them all going but that is the dream you
know you got your arcade you got your nacho living
station you got your booze got your dead guy booze
they're so good yeah I think we would be good in
the apocalypse I think we could make it we would
make it we would make it for a long time we would
be leaders I think so yeah we could start our own
camp we don't have to be fedra or fireflies we'll
just be the Switzerland right in the middle yeah
we're just like the the over here Camp is what
we'll call it if you want to be chill come over
here to the over here to the over here Camp yeah
that's a kiddie pool yeah oh that's fun yeah we
got a nacho cheese machine that we got working
again yep finally found all the spare parts thank
goodness be the most frivolous camp in the book
let's be honest is the only reason I'm here
at the over yeah I am at the over here camp we
got two books though we got all the pun books you
could ever want I love that too the whole the pun
book is like an important or you know it's like a
significant thread and I love that that comes up
like a couple episodes ago and you just think it's
like a random thing but it's like they don't even
make a huge deal out of it when she finds it and
then you realize like oh wait she just found like
one of her favorite books again like how great
yeah and now here yeah you see look oh no this was
like one of their things this is the way that she
keeps Riley alive in a way and keeps you know some
sanity in the friggin apocalypse You Gotta Laugh
a little bit you gotta laugh a lot to stay alive
yeah live laugh love that's what I always say
always say that always say it oh he says it always
live laugh love Eat Pray Love Eat Pray Love yeah
yeah that's what the infecteds do here is let's
get that eat pray with an e love life yeah they
learned it from Julia Robert too who's in that
movie right that was her yeah yeah she did so much
money that movie yeah historic amounts of money
yeah because she eat she prayed and she loved it
it was all on screen yeah it was recorded can't
sue that movie for false advertising no absolutely
not no because it's Julia she's you know we all
know she's Julia Roberts she eat she prayed she
left that's true absolute vodka yeah and props to
to the soldier guy I've seen that actor before I
thought he did a fine job trying to motivate Ellie
yeah he was good and I like their I like the way
I guess to kind of start to wrap it up I like that
they give you like you know kids find out about
politics kids find out about the world around
them and take stances based on various things and
I thought they realized that in a nice way where
yeah you have these two who are arguably being
sort of indoctrinated in different directions and
and that whole thing about like do you even fully
understand what it is you're getting into or what
it is you're railing against and the role of you
know Spin and rhetoric and propaganda amidst all
of that uh I thought they realized in a very sort
of nice way because there was real tension about
that and you could tell that they have currently
two very separate belief systems in certain ways
and I like the way that they use that for tension
and friction but without it just becoming like a
ah we don't see the world the same way we can't
do anything else sort of thing like they they
never cheap out on the on the dramatic affects
that those decisions have yeah it didn't become
overwhelming to and infect their relationship
like their relationship stayed even though their
moral ground I guess is a little bit different
in regards to fireflies and then the QC yeah
I'll come over the better fedra uh acronym
next time oh yeah what he did before I mean
it was good he's a fascist fascist what about uh
egotistical fascist egotistical dumbass radical
[__] I like it ass wipes they're ass that's why
that switches it up that's right yeah that's true
yeah that's true that's an even that's a because
that's a job then that's like a grunt job that's
not just a state of being any longer that's like
oh man what's my station in life I'm watching
the sewers yep no wonder Riley wanted to get out
there she was going to be put at the very end of
the fedra at the very end of the acronym it's
not where you want ass wipes were making her
you know and another [__] and uh yeah yeah the
collective [__] looking at the other ass wipes
worst version yeah it's a bad bad bad bad bad
not good not good but you know what was good
was love it was this episode Love Is Good Love is
good Mortal Combat is good carousels are good uh
lingerie can be good yeah uh and sneaking out
to the mall also always goody good always a
good time always a good time and uh and yeah
beating people up who take your Walkman yeah
always good always beat up someone who takes
your Walkman a Walkman should not be touched
ever ever like anyone if you have a Walkman right
now and it's on you and somebody goes to like hey
can I no just punch him immediately don't even
stop it don't even think about it no just say
knock them out well all right we settled that
score settle you heard it here you got any any
stray thoughts before we hit the road nope just
work on your punches if if you've got a Walkman
work on those punches subscribe hit the like
button and last but not least let's do a little
Chris Wham off you knew this was coming buddy
listen man I want you and my apocalypse Camp
my team all right you are the guy who people
in the apocalypse you know in the in the group
will probably give a lot of Guff to some of
the time the guy people would be like oh man
you know we gotta take action we gotta you know be
formidable we gotta you know show people we're not
to be messed with but you would help us maintain
humanity and even if people argue that that's an
easy way to get killed in the apocalypse we
cannot no no let go of our humanity and you
you're a selfless kind-hearted person Chris and
that's what we need to repopulate the world with
you know what I mean oh so yeah I mean Chris is
going to be basically the he's holding down the
gene pool sure the deal over here yeah we're
gonna have to make you this at the epicenter
of the effort to repopulate the world yes we want
those kindness genes to flow so you're gonna have
to just get down with anyone and everyone who's
willing yeah you really get a responsible get
used to it now I know what you're thinking wow
that's a lot of responsibility but honestly no
way to avoid it man it's lots of fun yeah just
dive and avoid fun dive in dive dive dive Chris
love you buddy stay pledged to our little
qz our little quarantine Patron Hideout
here the over here Camp the over here
Camp I like it the ohc I love you Chris
and we'll catch you next month stay
well and uh yeah sign off words peace